hello and congratulations
thank you very much nice to see you me
too so
i wanted to start with the look of your
grand high witch
and specifically if there was any major
difference between
day one of figuring out what she would
look like and what we see in the final
film
no bob and i had a lot of preliminary
conversations of where we wanted to go
um and i said to him i kind of want her
to look like she got stuck in a
hitchcock movie
and uh bob really liked that idea so i
don't know maybe the wig was a little
bigger on day one and we and
if you can believe it we toned it down
but um
but no no no we we just kind of it was a
lot of yes
and on this job we didn't overthink
things we went with our instincts and it
was a lot of fun
and a lot and there's a lot of talented
people executing it so
so what about the face mold process
because i saw that video you posted you
seem super chill about it but
i imagine it's not comfortable but is
there any anxiety with going through
that
you know it doesn't matter if there is
or there isn't you just it's a part of
the job and you just kind of gotta
do it and it's not forever and the the
one part was
um the reason the second half of the
video is as long as the first is because
i got stuck
so that part was crazy
because and i just felt like okay
because i could feel the guys around me
trying to get me out of it getting a
little
like you know they were getting anxious
so i'm like it i have to be the calm one
if i can stay calm nothing bad can
happen
have you ever heard the jeff daniels
story i feel like i can see
that's the other thing by the way as
they're putting it on me they're telling
me the jeff daniels story
and i'm just like this is kind of
brilliant because anything that goes
wrong i have in my mind that it could be
worse
so maybe set me up beautifully for that
i'll never be able to unhear that
rumbling exactly that that part is the
worst of it all
um i also wanted to ask you about the
evolution of the accent and
at what point did you figure out exactly
what felt right to you for that
character
it took a minute you know we we explored
so many different
sounds uh because i really wanted to
respect what roll doll had written and
all of those syllables but just trying
to figure out
kind of where the vowels lived i'm
getting so wonky an actor you have to
excuse me i
it was a fun process for me but it's
probably deadly doll to hear about
so um so we my dialect coach joan
washington and i we
we tried norwegian and we tried swedish
and all of them sounded a little light a
little contemporary
and then it was jones idea to say well
they're both you know all scandinavian
accents are based on norse
so maybe we could see if we could find
an example of old norse
and then we found this poetry professor
reciting nurse poetry on the internet
and um and joan kind of created a
dialect from that
and now it's in a movie i can listen to
that stuff all day so i appreciate you
going into depth on that
before i have to wrap up with you i did
want to ask about catwoman and
specifically
what advice you might have for zoe
kravitz different
movie different director i'm sure she
has her own interpretation on the role
but maybe something that worked really
well for you in terms of making the most
of that process that might come in handy
for her or really anyone else who takes
that character on
you saw the picture of her coming down
the stairs right yeah she doesn't need
my advice
excellent response pitch perfect i
believe in her
and i love your take as well thank you
and by the way if i had any advice it
would be literally don't listen to
anybody
because i think the only way to play
that role as if is is to give
your version of it you know and we all
all of us had different directors
and we and all of our interpretations
were specific to the films that they
were in kind of like my
grand thai which is specific to bob
zemeckis and angelica houston is
specific to
uh nicholas rogues and and that's great
and all the jokers were specific to each
director they have and so i don't think
you can
get too bogged down with the comparison
and especially when you're not the one
doing it
because your job is to to give the yours
and i'm so excited to see what she does
with it i thought she was a perfect
choice
as a mind i feel like that mentality is
why i enjoy seeing different
interpretations of these characters on
screen
oh good good i pray for people like you
in the audience
it's all good thank you so much and
again huge congratulations on this one
thank you so much